we've watched the Reagan foreign-policy
now for the last seven years we've had
you on many times to discuss those what
is distinctive about Reagan's foreign
policy what did he try to do different
from his predecessors well he set out 30
years ago to affect a major lasting
change on the United States political
system a radical change and he pursued
it to get himself into the White House
to effect this change and he's done it
to a degree perhaps not too you know he
hasn't iced the cake certainly not the
way he hoped the Iran amok thing is
deflected and and his own corruption of
the corruption around him but no other
president in history
I don't believe can make a case of
setting out as a middle-aged man to
affect a dramatic change on this society
and come as close as this man has and
what is the nature of this change well
first you have to understand and accept
which is hard for some but you read the
man's biography the and we know him well
he's been a public figure four or five
decades radio announcer and then
politician activist and in Hollywood he
has never been a conservative with a
small C he has always been drawn to
radical activities and propensity
towards right-wing radical activities
even when he was posing as a liberal
protector of the people who were being
blacklisted from the Screen Actors Guild
and whatnot he was in fact cooperating
as a friend with the house on American
Affairs Committee and with Richard
Nixon's red-baiting vicious political
campaign in California then you see
other indications when he was governor
the San Diego Navy assassination school
which was teaching very heavy techniques
of torture and killing he's under the
CIA no this was u.s. Navy a navy killer
school in San Diego when was it and this
was in the late 60s Reagan was governor
acalypha bet and Reagan was was honoring
them and mentioning them and
going to call on you bet it loves the
military for some reason he has an
absolute fascination with military
action and personnel and ships and
weapons and power and control second
thing you can cite was this California
special training institute that we've
mentioned before at San Luis Obispo in
1969 it began with operation what was it
called cable splice or splicing with
Luis Jill Frieda putting it together
with generals from the Pentagon and the
National Guard as well as corporate
executives assembling for a seminar to
discuss techniques of population control
repression heavy duty stuff the
disinformation the torture the planning
informants the phony groups the
concentration camps the concentration
camps the curfews the martial law all of
these techniques and Reagan gave the
opening address to the seminar the
secret they all wore civilian clothes
you know the media wouldn't and he gave
the opening address and his words were
something to the effect you know there
are some people in the state who if they
could see us all assembled here today
would say that their worst fears are
being recognized that I'm planning a
military takeover and then this thing
under his encouragement proceeded to
become the California special training
institute and continues so that by 1979
UPI reported that it had graduated
14,000 people a mine just 14,000
generals and admirals and executives in
foreign countries as well as from
foreign countries as well and this is
coordinated with Isis a with
corporations with a communications
apparatus in the United States all
telephone company prominently and with
the police apparatus and with the I the
CIA police also as well police officers
and sheriff's being brought in from all
over the nation to be briefed on these
techniques and associate you know
creating a police cult if you will now
so Reagan proceeds to get himself
elected president with the help of the
people that he was funding for but you
know it's his it's his program - it
isn't just that they made him it's what
he's been working for and they've joined
with him and he comes into office
promising to affect the Reagan
Revolution and to permanently change the
society now he has told us many many
times what he would have done if he had
been president during the Vietnam War
and he wasn't bluffing his his attitude
towards dissidents in California during
the war you know if there has to be a
bloodbath let's get it over with
and he wasn't bluffing he called out the
National Guard and gave them orders to
shoot to kill and then he comes into the
White House one element of the
revolution is to shatter the government
to gain control of it by breaking it
down putting in his own people very
radical people who would smash it would
break up the bureaucracy and all the
little relationships and everything you
know James Watt and Burford for example
Elliott Abrams he was but you remember
in charge of the Human Rights Division
of the State Department sending the
files back to the countries in question
and then the immigration naturalization
service sending the people back to the
countries as well I mean this is these
are heavy duty these people are playing
hardball it's a revolution to them
that's what they call it
Alfred Regnery you know this have you
sucked your kid that was his bumper
sticker put in charge of the Juvenile
Division of the Justice Department how
do you talk to your kids yeah the guy
his his pediatrician went to Washington
to testify to the committee's saying you
can never put this man in a job where he
has to deal with young people I know
because I treat his family and he was
nominated for the Juvenile Division of
the Justice Department and you know you
know the hundreds yeah there are there
parallel things you look at the National
Labor Relations Board stacked against
the Union you look at the health
organizations where they're going
they're going to have ketchup for a
vegetable all the way through the
government like you say ray King the
liberal mindset you know of the
government and and then throughout
trying to pass laws that would reinforce
and a lot of laws we get or you know the
Army Corps of Engineers making a law
about the environment and some local and
it's a law it's enforced by the judges
even though the Congress never voted on
it
agencies applying on presidential orders
setting up laws lots of laws he's passed
but in addition to that this forty five
percent of the judges that he's appoint
the federal judges almost half that he's
managed to a point since he's been in
office now radical right radical crazy
people like William Rehnquist the
documented racist and bigoted as at the
top of the Supreme Court and and Daniel
Mannion you know this illiterate
attorney can't write a paper the son of
the John Birch Society founder made it
just people like that so that when they
get this when they get the test of the
Revolution when they when they pull it
together they will have done all of
their homework all of the paid work the
preparation will have been done so that
they can make it stick now what the
Reagan Revolution has been is to get the
pendulum you know as it swings over to
the right and then weld it shut with the
laws with the judges with the control of
the government
now the key has been in their planning
has been a war a war you have a national
you know security emergency you can
declare martial law you can take
emergency measures and war that you
can't argue in peacetime and this is
where they were heading towards the
invasion of Nicaragua and it was
derailed by the not just the iran-contra
scandal although that definitely derail
that are postponed it but also the break
apart of the reagan machine there was
just so much corruption he had too many
incompetent wild men running the thing
for him dealing with people like oliver
north when he should have had the
carlucci's in there to begin with
who would do about the same thing but
more credibly more and more more soberly
more sane and worth more credibility in
the establishment he was beginning to
come apart last fall before the
iran-contra thing crashed brought him
down to a point now the big question
that we we debate everywhere i debated
everywhere i discuss it with Daniel
Ellsberg's and David McMichaels as I
travel and lots of other people is
whether or not he will succeed
and invading Nicaragua and that's a
horror unto itself but I have the
feeling that people miss the broader
implications of this invasion when it
happens now the Christian Institute this
flawed affidavit it has a segment on the
Rex 84 the detention centers the FEMA
the Federal Emergency Management Agency
which is part of this plan which is to
to prepare detention centers and laws
and an infrastructure across the country
so that when they pull off the invasion
they will be able to to sweep 400,000
people off the streets and throw them in
detention centers now this one I asked
the FEMA people the the Silber ones
there if they really had this documented
because we talked about this Rex 80 for
two or three years ago and the spotlight
had mentioned it but it wasn't really
proven and they assured me they said yes
they have this one from top attorneys
within FEMA who have admitted to it and
they got it documented plus they have
all the laws from 1950 still on the
books the McCarran act which sets up
concentration camps and all the special
powers which the president has written
declare a emergency at any time without
getting anybody's approval and putting
all these things into effect taking over
the banking system transportation system
the Broadcasting System and incarcerated
hey everybody I think there's another
aspect of this desire to invade
Nicaragua and that was the crime would
be the crowning blow of the Reagan
Revolution the fulfillment of it I think
that in this iran-contra hearings we've
been seeing all of the anti-communism of
these people that were involved in the
north network and in the Reagan foreign
policy operators who literally believed
in the domino theory that if Nicaragua
and El Salvador quote/unquote one
communist then that would be a domino
effect going through Guatemala Honduras
Mexico to the United States and we would
face a communist takeover of this
country he came into office promising
you know
the Grenada Nicaragua and Cuba and he
did you know after the Grenada thing
they had bumper stickers out and he cut
Iowa next al haig now Cuba is a tougher
nut it's better defended they can't do
it the cost I talked to these Admirals
up in Washington often enough and they
continuously reassure me that our
Pentagon no president here is foolish
enough to try to pull off an invasion of
Cuba not that we couldn't win but it
would be so bloody and so expensive and
there would be so much damage done it
would be fought in part in the United
States I mean we would you know we would
obliterate Cuba but the Cubans would
take a toll in our own cities here and
no politician could survive that
you know John we've been as part of the
Reagan administration we've been talking
about foreign policy that's our emphasis
well I think we should briefly also talk
about the economic aspects of the Reagan
Revolution which also have been very
successful from his point of view
the severe weakening of the labor unions
and the working-class institutions that
have been developed since the 1930s the
lowering of the standard of living of
most Americans a tremendous transfer of
wealth and income from the middle and
lower classes up to the upper classes
but at the same time he seriously
destabilized the economy of the United
States by being such a great adherent of
free-market ISM and deregulation it has
particularly caused chaos in the banking
and investment industry where these
corporate raiders have come in and
seriously destabilized the economy so
although he is it's been a two-edged
sword but nonetheless he has carried out
the Reagan Revolution in this aspect -
there's another element where the
economics impact on foreign policy and
the other issues we've discussed and
that's the military buildup the Reagan
administration has spent two trillion
dollars on weapons since coming into
office the whole cost of Vietnam
according to some analyses that I read
was one trillion dollars so Reagan has
spent twice as much as was spent on the
entire Vietnam episode from the early
60s to the mid
70 simply in a military weapons build-up
and has done this without raising taxes
and has thus build up the biggest
deficit in history without being an
economist I read and watch these things
since you know since George Bush called
it voodoo economics the the deficit the
rendering the United States
non-competitive the way he has done when
we were already headed in that direction
he has applied the same irresponsibility
to economics that he's applied to
breaking up the government the Alfred
Regnery syndrome the Elliott Abrams type
of appointment this is where his
position in history as David McMichael
was telling me over the phone last night
he said the next president be he
Democrat are all Republican it's going
to be a Herbert Hoover yes he's going to
preside over a gigantic collapse now how
big this collapse will be nobody knows
but the damage that has been done
economically 50 years maybe we will dig
ourselves out of this out of this debt
out of the balance maybe maybe and and
at the other end of a Lloyd dumas you
know and his book he brought out last
year the article he ran at the New York
Times is is a slow decline or sudden
collapse but his his thesis in this book
is that this this madness of Reaganomics
when we were already not competitive has
put us on the slide down and it's we are
sliding down and unless we dramatically
reverse are the arms race essentially
the military-industrial complex control
we're going down as a superpower we'll
go down into secondary national status
if we slide if we don't okay so these
are expensive fantasies that Reagan has
which also we haven't mentioned it was
his early desire to destroy the Soviet
Union it seems that he really had the
fantasy of eradicating the evil empire
he really was pursuing the option very
seriously of an
weapons build-up that would enable him
to carry out a first strike policy and
eliminate the Soviet Union or to create
such military nuclear superiority that
he could dictate to the Soviet Union
because they would be afraid of his
military power and I think this is also
behind the Star Wars with this flawed
person the the the individual with I
mean I've you know I've said since 83 in
my lectures you know pointing out his
defective mind which is which is obvious
and now so obvious that I scarcely even
bothered because everyone realizes that
you know he simply can't keep up with
things he's had this drive this dream is
this radical bent that would affect a
revolution but not a kind of intellect
that could really weave a revolution
together but this flawed personality
apparently dating back to the childhood
with the abusive alcoholic father who
could not give him an image to live up
to and at the same time emasculated him
with abuse so you have reagan's own
autobiography the theme of it is this
haunting sense of inadequacy that has
driven him all his life and that's the
theme of the book and the title he took
from one of his movies is where is the
rest of me and this you know is is being
cited by the psychological studies that
are coming out now as why he would have
this craving for military power you know
to be complete to be strong why he could
be so offended by petty world leaders
like Qaddafi for example who you know
would discredit themselves you a more
complete person wouldn't get involved in
the arguments with them and he is he has
continuously gotten down to the same
level of petty name-calling with them of
threatening or wanting expressing his
desire to make Daniel Ortega cry uncle
and you know I mean the bullying aspect
of it she would have to have someone
with the bully syndrome with a very
inadequate personality he would crave to
make a Daniel Ortega in a poor country
like Nicaragua cry uncle
and this you know taking it into the
Reaganomics into the Star Wars wanting
to control the world wanting to be able
to crush his enemies it's a dangerous
dangerous dangerous combination does
Hollywood play any role in this
Hollywood movies over the last 40 years
have projected this fantasy that the
world is divided into good and evil
there's us and them the good guys the
bad guys we're absolutely good they're
absolutely evil they are so evil that if
we don't eradicate them just eliminate
them through violence they're going to
get us do you think this contributes to
Reagan's mentality that he identified
with these Hollywood roles in this view
of the world you think it's sort of
deeper psychological roots oh it's it's
all part it's deeper psychologically but
it's also very it's the American
syndrome and television the cultural the
game that we put on to our kids from the
age of two that they watch 10 or 20
times a day on television the little
shorty cartoons where you have nice
handsome light-colored hero figures be
they transformers you know and
Decepticons or the the he-man Sheena the
Thundercats you know I'm into these
things because of little Jonathan but
always the nice people and evil forces
rising up and the nice people saying
let's all be nice but the evil force is
insisting and forcing and then the good
guy is stomping them and beating them
down but interestingly enough to keep
the syndrome going for the little kids
Skeletor you know never is killed he
changes for him and disappears so he can
come back net the next day and do it
again
now we brainwash our kids like I say 10
or 20 times a day with this the American
syndrome nice people being put upon by
evil and and going would you would you
do you realize there is a country in
this hemisphere that does not permit
violent shows to be shown on television
for children Nicaragua now it's Cuba
Cuba Cuba they do not permit violent
kids shows on television they believe
it's psychologically unhealthy and we do
nothing but
assuming the Democrats or even another
Republican gets in next time is how has
he done so much damage that they're
gonna to put it back together again
or as we well know he could have done it
without the Democrats collusion in the
House and Senate so just where do we go
after Reagan's out well this is a
possible explanation of why and this
democratically controlled Senate is not
doing a better job investigating the
iran-contra thing this Reagan who has
bedeviled them for so many years now
they have him all they have to do is
start asking the questions and they can
rip this thing right apart and having
impeached and they're not interested and
my suggestion is the the Reagan
Revolution is not a Republican
revolution it's the establishments
revolution it's getting the pendulum
over here and welding it shut for the
benefit of the multinationals the
military-industrial complex of which the
Democrats are just as much a part as the
Republicans now he has supervised dat
tremendous arms build-up but remember
Jimmy Carter
you know supervised two huge arms
build-up and so did Harry Truman for
justice I - not to mention Lyndon
Johnson and Carter also presided over a
tax cut tax benefit for the wealthy at
the expense of the middle indeed and so
they don't want to throw out the whole
revolution they don't want to sacrifice
Reagan and cast the country throw the
country back into a populist mode
there's been a tremendous shift of
wealth under mr. Reagan I'm quoting now
from Chomsky's turning the tide and
writing the shift of wealth and power to
the elite at the expense of the people
wealth and power the political power the
ketchup and relish thing in the schools
you know just the whole rationale of
society the dynasty and Dallas thing you
know the rich rich and glittery taking
over they don't want to lose that the
satisfaction they would get out of
impeaching Reagan isn't worth it because
they would lose his revolution which is
gains for
for their their level their strata of
society power level in their social
class in a social class you know the
establishment the military-industrial
complex one of the keys to understanding
the Reagan administration is
understanding its relationships with
their religious right many of whose
adherents are high officials in the
Reagan administration including Reagan
himself we've referred to particular
sections of this covert action
information bulletin edition let's see
what's that number 27 anyway it's the
latest one I guess I'm like July or June
it tells all you want to know almost all
you want to know about the religious
right and it's incredible how not only
what some of these people believe but
how they're organized among themselves
and their interrelationships with the
United States government in corporate
America they're not just these weirdos
who you know hoop and holler and rant
and rave on on television as matter
factor according to Robertson's
Christian Broadcasting Network they say
the bulk of their contributions actually
come from the big corporations in the
United States but the religious right is
a complex coalition according to Larry
Hickam who's been studying this for some
time it's a complex coalition of
independent organizations ranging from
those well-known that we've been talking
about and wealthy international with
wealthy international television
networks like CBN to smaller
organizations where there's a few TV
stations or small network here and there
but they also are interlocked with as I
said corporate America and the
government for instance there are many
many organizations which they form one
particularly is called the Full Gospel
business men's fellowship international
now these are all fundamentalists
including a hodgepodge of charismatic
and all that type Pentecostals and these
in some parts of the country
particularly in the Sun Belt State
this organization The Full Gospel
business man's fellowship called the FGB
MFI seemed like they'd come up with a
better acronym than that anyway they're
made up largely of people who managed a
military-industrial complex president
reagan has close ties with the
organization and a lot of his top
advisors are from this organization and
they're you know they believe in the
Armageddon and the Second Coming and
we're in the last days and all like that
so they these people have meetings from
time to time some are located in for
most of them are more highly organized
but they have breakfast is breakfast
where they talk about the coming of
Jesus and how nuclear weapons will lead
to the second coming of Jesus and so and
so many of these people see there's a
difference the people who believe in the
rapture the Summum who believe that
they're going to be raptured you know
taken up to heaven before just before
the Big Bang so they're not sweating
World War three at all they don't care
and some of these people are in high in
the government and as I said just
involved in the military industrial
complex and even working with nuclear
weapons now there are other people who
believe in the rapture of they believe
that they're going to fry a while
separately before they're raptured and
then Robertson feels that they'll go
through the whole thing but the God will
kind of take it easy on protect them a
bit from the good guys
yeah so as the person here says you
wrote the article the idea that a key
network of key workers in the
military-industrial complex along with
others who are key decision-makers in a
nuclear chain of command may all be and
you know have these expectations of
Armageddon and how great it's going to
be makes you kind of worried a bit well
there's something even more worrisome
about this whole thing and that is the
Ronald Reagan himself believes in
rapture and
Armageddon there's an article in some
cultural journal that I saw that
indicates that at 12 different occasions
Reagan has spoken seriously about the
rapture and his belief that nuclear war
might possibly be the Armageddon that
had been predicted in Revelations and at
this time the good people like him and
Jerry farwell would ascend to heaven
while the rest of us would fry this is
particularly scary as we move into the
last year or so of the Reagan
administration because if a tenth of the
stories that we've been reporting on
alternative views are true concerning
the scandals in the iran-contra affair
and the entire Reagan administration
there's been nothing but a series of one
crimes after another if all of these
stories break in the mass media there's
no question but the Reagan will be
impeached
so the frightening scenario is that just
as he's about to go he decides that
we'll all go together when we go as
family justice in the 1950s and it's
time for the rapture to come and the
buttons to be pushed so I hope that if
there's a attempt to impeach Reagan
there's also someone that has a very
close look at the nuclear weapons
buttons to keep the old guy from blowing
us all away as he goes out well as the
this article continues it talks about
these people are you know just not a
bunch of Reagan crazies here we're still
the Secretary of Defense built to prayer
rooms at the Pentagon again they have
these organized Bible study groups for
admirals and generals in the Pentagon
members of Congress and their aides and
here are some of the people who are who
go to these prayer rooms at the
Secretary of Defense
it's people like chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff Commandant of the Marine
Corps Chief of Naval Operations chief of
staff in the army
and we're not talking about just a bunch
of crazy underlings we're talking about
the big people who've got their fingers
on the button up there according to the
religious right Armageddon will occur as
a result of a clash between the Soviet
Union and the United States in the
Middle East well the situation in
the Persian Gulf looms rather large and
significant john stockwell gives his
opinion president reagan has avoided
confrontation in the gulf for for six
years now they've been shooting up oil
tankers and that's terribly threatening
I mean if if I you know our leaders
wanted some that's the sort of thing I
mean the Angolan operation because the
Soviets could theoretically put in a
submarine base that would threaten the
South Atlantic to cut off the flow of
oil you know in the tankers coming up
through the South Atlantic that was the
rationale that they they were using for
that thing and here we have countries
that are actually strafing and shooting
and thinking oil tankers and we've done
nothing about it and the reason I submit
is geographical can you imagine what
Reagan would do if Nicaragua shot up an
oil think or if Grenada had our you know
our cue some country our Libya is if
Qaddafi had ordered an oil tanker in the
Mediterranean to be shot up but the
reason is that the fight of war way
around on the backside very hard to get
to very hard to resupply very hard to
get the American people you know deeply
involved and so they have avoided time
after time a provocation in addition to
which they don't want to do anything to
push Iran in the direction of the Soviet
Union the the Soviets are no more happy
with Khomeini then you know then we are
and an open heavy duty attack on Iran
could could cost us the influence that
we've had over the years in that country
that's right on the Soviet border now
mr. Reagan has clearly gotten involved
the provocations putting our ships in
there where they're right in the way
where they could get shot up and two of
them have been attacked and the start
more dramatically and then the huge
focus of interest on the stark you
people are drawing parallels in the
question marks the Marines in the
barracks and Beirut in 1983 were not
allowed to carry bullets and their guns
the ones guarding the the barracks you
know we're not allowed to have armed
weapons who ended up and killed oh yeah
and and you know this perfectly open now
we had intercepts that
this barracks was going to be targeted
and they didn't take the precautions of
putting the big concrete thing so a
truck going in would have to go like
this which would give you time to react
and shoot out its tires that it's a very
basic in a base like that they left them
exposed and then you have this the stark
over there just not defending itself at
all so you have now with all of which is
to say that they have clearly targeted
Reagan has clearly targeted the Gulf now
and the obvious purpose would be to get
the world attention off of the hearings
but I don't think he wants to get
involved in a big war there I think he
wants some macho and there may be some
more missiles fired in different
directions maybe some bombing and
whatnot but I don't believe he wants to
get involved in a war there but he would
like to be able to turn up the fire
every now and then there to draw
attention off over over in Washington
and the hearings and God knows maybe
heated up enough that he can eventually
pull off the invasion in Nicaragua I'm
still by the way my wager Macabre sad
sick wager in 81 that the United States
would invade Nicaragua and I have not
you guys more likely than a war in the
yeah and I have not retracted that I
believe that Reagan is still trying very
hard and very likely will succeed